One thing to point out.
We did start off by saying that this
is a plane, and we put a camera here.
I rotate a camera about a projection
point, we create a planar surface or
a mosaic.
Of course, this projection
plane can also be a cylinder.
Or a sphere which basically would
have curvatures on both sides.
And again, by knowing this kind of stuff
we would actually be able to then also
do the similar kinds of projections.
So here I'm just
rotating around a plane.
But as I said, I could rotate
in this way, capture a cylinder,
which basically has this thing.
And also, in many instances,
move the camera up and down and
also represent a sphere.
So in essence bo,
basically be able go up and down.
And this basically allows us to be
able to generate different types of
panoramas.
And we've looked at this
kind of stuff before.
This basically showcases three
different types of panoramas.
A planar panorama,
which basically is trying to make
straight lines be straight lines.
Of course, you notice that all
the lines are straight here.
But this is more of
a spherical panorama,
where the lines in the middle
are straight, but if you look them,
they curve around pretty badly at
the edges, and stuff like that.
And, of course cylindrical panorama
is like this, where, again,
we can actually model these
types of things correctly.